Marla and Tony your reaction was my
reaction backstage watching Oh shocker
completely every part of me doesn't
understand this part the judges
including guests zendaya called last
night's performance one of their best so
was a shock to see Marla and partner
Tony Dovolani go home but Marla had some
support her daughter with the Donald
Tiffany was in the audience knows how to
overcome the sadness that taught her a
lot a shirtless now DiMarco didn't skip
a beat the hearing-impaired model kept
perfect time with partner Peta
Murgatroyd but told Cameron rehearsals
were a different story now you're
jumping around all over the place how's
your body holding up any any injuries to
speak up when I kick the tree I didn't
cut my foot all right I realized that
I'm Tarzan Jody sweet we forgot the
moves to hurt cha cha with partner
Chioma sempai but the top two of the
night were UFC fighter planes van zan
and ginger Zee who was definitely the
belle of the ball
how's the body holding up in the
injuries my feet and my ankles I like
I'm with compression sack my friends are
in town I tried to go to dinner with
that I tried to look cool like with some
ripped jeans and then I realized I have
old lady compression socks